it's a party that's over 200 years old
on February 28th beads will fill the air
parades will fill the streets and a
spirit of Mardi Gras will once again
transform New Orleans with its first
Mardi Gras since Hurricane Katrina New
Orleans is struggling to recapture its
Big Easy Spirit just six months ago the
hurricane flooded the city and claimed
the lives of over 1,300 people but
despite the tragedy some residents vowed
the traditional Mardi Gras would go on
the holiday was first brought to New
Orleans by the city's French Catholic
settlers in the Catholic Church
believers fast pray and repent for 40
days to ready their souls for Easter
Sunday this special season called Lent
begins on Ash Wednesday during medieval
times the day before that became known
as Fat Tuesday because Kooks used up all
the butter and fat in the kitchen before
the deprivation of Lent began and in
French Fat Tuesday translates as Mardi
Gras Mardi Gras is also the final day of
the worldwide Carnival season which
kicks off around the globe as early as
January 6 carnival circles the planet
with a worldwide party and the most
famous carnival of all takes place in
the streets of Rio de Janeiro set to the
beat of Samba music Carnaval means
elaborate costumes floats and dancing in
the streets on American soil
New Orleans first celebrated Mardi Gras
with elaborate balls then in 1857 the
secret society of Comus staged the first
parade with floats and the modern Mardi
Gras was born New Orleans is still
rebounding from Katrina's devastation
but celebrating its most famous holiday
may be one step toward recovery